here is the result of the philately  constituency early V a so vogue Canon  yada and has perceived ROI in board  never applied lacy I average drawers  bought in or am case will fell again  Lynn I the returning officer hereby give  notice that the number of votes recorded  for each candidate is as follows  Arthur Murray Frances gainer 7351 scythe  Niall tree hunt him day again Daniels  Rory 548 pimp can't pedrad egg earth  Davis Steven Andrew nine thousand five  hundred forty four now meal M can't  Edward egg off Edwin Griffith Nia three  on on 21,000 diving email infant feeding  reefs n 1331 in meal tree hunt tree dig  in a curve and dark and rowing in road  near Griffith ready Kyle IFO and  pre-order an eyelid Synod Oh gross Ethel  life are annoyed and I hereby declare  that Nia Griffith is duly elected member  of parliament for the said constituency  [Applause]